today on our show marvelous marks movies
of 2016 the ones he liked best
number five through number one today
welcome to fat man of America Smith I'm
open oh and guess what
huh we're in the middle of something you
caught us in the middle of [ __ ] hey we
were talking about last episode marks
top 10 of 2016
mm-hm and he did four honorable mentions
and he did number ten through number six
remind them title wise what those were
honorable mentions the handmaiden
Zootopia Kubo and the two strings
Manchester by the sea number ten
Oh Jay made in America long ass
documentary long as [ __ ] 797 hours
but accounts is moving yes rogue one you
know you know train to Busan South
Koreans aam betray and film which is the
movie on everyone's lips
absolutely yes I'm talking about a good
flick zombies on a train
Deadpool number seven needs no
explanation number six hell or high
water
Captain Kirk in the Old West that's
right Jeff Jeff Bridges Jeff as we say
in America not GA three ages as they say
in Russia I thought you were going South
America I think we all know cougar and
Chris Pine as one fossa the angel and
foster the angel from the x-men movies
among so he was in 3:10 to Yuma he was
he's good actor Bill he's really good
when he gets to wear like a handlebar
mustache yeah when he gets to kind of
bury himself in a little bit of
businesses and dust I would argue he's
pretty much good all the time but you're
right when he gets to he's especially
sharp when yeah I'm one of these y'all I
was gonna be dirty
alright so there's your top six six now
we dive into the top five marks
journey through cinema 2016 indeed
finishes now number five number five
Milana oh the cartoon the cartoon real
that's deep on your list
yes that beats your bow like who won the
two strains in Zootopia Zootopia that
meatsuit Opia yeah tell the story good
I'm part of it is like we talked about
with rogue one like seeing rub one at
the premiere see it in that room made
that a special experience
I saw Moana election night like I went
to a screening because I'm like I would
like to not be around for two hours
right and I really need the [ __ ] this
is what movies are made for take me the
[ __ ] you attic disappear me from the
world for two hours and for those two
hours to go and see this story about the
sort of plucky young girl who happens to
be a girl of color who saves her village
by being brave and by understanding like
sort of social dynamics and and how to
deal with the environment and deal with
the masculine energy of somebody like
the rock and save the day like that was
a wonderful place to be for a while
perfect timing perfect timing for that
have you seen it more than that time I
had got the the award screener for it
and even if I got mine yeah and it
really holds up it holds up in in great
part because the two dudes who did it
Ron Musker and John Clements also did
Aladdin also do beating the beast like
these dudes no [ __ ] [ __ ] Disney so
it moves and it's fun and it's funny and
and it's incredibly rich and the music
is phenomenal because it's by lin-manuel
miranda so all of the songs are Hamilton
level good cheese and the rock is super
[ __ ] fun that's just what he does he
sold me a ticket see yes Moana number
five I cannot speak highly enough of
that number four number four lala land
Damien Chazelle Damien she's a demon
she's al he's like Joseph Damien
Chazelle bündchen so if she marries
damages I'll she'd be Giselle Giselle
yes you do it just for the puns
unless he's previously engaged I'm not
entirely sure but just for our purposes
would be great this I've watched yet my
kid [ __ ] love this movie came home
bawling like this
I mean I saw it in a screening like six
people in the room and it opens with
this Technicolor musical sequence on
like the 110 it's like on an on an exit
ramp onto an LA freeway and it's just
all primary colors and music and energy
and 50s MGM musicals and sixties French
New Wave musicals like umbrellas of
Cherbourg or singing in the rain and and
it's just parts of this movie of magic
and the kind of magic you don't see that
much anymore and that kind of throwback
like oh [ __ ] we're just gonna sing like
that thing the musicals do where we sing
what we feel because we can't say it too
then have that mated with the story of a
young actress and a struggling jazz man
played by Ryan Reynolds Gosling and Emma
Stone totally different movie it just it
all worked for me like even the parts
that don't work work for me because I'm
as much as like me and Harley loved this
movie there's lots of people who don't
love this movie right primarily the kids
liked it there's there's this this sort
of undercurrent against it primarily
because Ryan Gosling's character is a
bit of a dick and so my wife
specifically found it hard to sympathize
with him in any way or with her through
certain degree for being with him
because we could all say he's a dick why
can't she sees a dick I choose to
interpret it as Ryan Gosling is the
final boss that she needs to defeat
before she can become the truly
actualized person that she is and by the
end of the movie you see spoilers what
would you see like her best destiny is
what the end of the movie is about
including his tragic flaw and how it
undercuts what his best destiny could
have been but no it's just magical in
parts it's wonderful this is the boy
that did whiplash which is awesome as
well which is also the story about how
you create a villain it is just nothing
but like you're a pretty good kid I'm a
bullet headed [ __ ] I'm going to turn
you into Magneto how am I gonna do that
with jazz by the end of that movie when
you see them like vibing with each other
and like oh yeah you're perfect now
you've hammered out all emotion from
your music you become a wonderful
monotonous metronomic villain person
just like me and then you
yeah it's how to make a super villain
and this movie is how to defeat your
final boss it's like a video game
comic-book filmmaker buried working in
class immature absolutely all right so
that's number four that's number four
worth watching man all are sure I feel
like I'm a tree number tree Captain
America Civil War aah
also this year we love this movie ah I
mean much like much like rug one like
this feels like it's everything I've
ever wanted in the comic boom yeah hey
boy I mean like there this is marvel
cooking on all cylinders like you know
oh we know how to do this yeah totally
it's like that Airport sequence alone
much like the duck Vader sequence it's
just mmm I cannot get enough of the one
major sequence times a thousand even
just if it had just been them running
any friends who have been like that was
awesome but you Jayant man and man
become a giant man [ __ ] panther
spider-man the Spider Man we all wanted
to see forever oh yeah festive thrilling
filming yeah there's there's so much
that works in that movie all hail the
Russo brothers
all hail the Russo's that's number three
number two number two arrival to grab I
love this movie my favorite screenplay
of the year and that's saying something
cuz there was some really well-written
[ __ ] yeah but that screenplay is
absolutely magical that movie is
insanely well directed her performance
is haunting it's it's emotionally
affecting its [ __ ] if you're remotely
inclined to movies that have meaning and
this is a sci-fi movie yeah like on the
surface what you've been sold if you saw
trailer about like aliens are coming you
have not been lied to that is what the
movie is but it is so not what that
movie is it's a beautiful beautiful
scary thrilling mysterious like half the
time you looked up [ __ ] going on but
when they finally bring it all together
and they click at home you you bro
instantly roll tears it isn't that
[ __ ] stunning and beautiful yeah
negatory - it does the thing that
science fiction is supposed to do like
great science fiction does which is
allegorical storytelling
is let me tell you a story about you
buried in a story about something
fantastical and this is a story about
communication it's a story about you
know overcoming the differences between
people so that you can actually
communicate you can actually make
progress that you can actually save the
world and again and tough for them to
communicate because they were like outer
space knuckles but you know and again
this is one of those movies that came
out in September it premiered at Toronto
out in theaters in like late October
mm-hmm just as the election was coming
up to speed and it felt like this like
it's a movie of this time it's by the
fact that it was in the works for a year
a good year and a half beforehand right
but it hit this perfect nexus point
between want and need like I needed to
escape I wanted to hear something
hopeful and that's kind of what this
movie was mmm perfect so that's number
two number two arrivals take this home
pop or your favorite movie of 2016
Markman Arden was moonlight oh I still
haven't seen my moon Wow yeah yeah sorry
Jenkins who had only made one other
movie before this a small film that get
that did well enough but been you know
blow up in any real way but it is this
sort of triptych of a story following
sort of three periods in the life of
this young black kid in the Liberty
Heights sort of ghetto sections of Miami
as he comes to grip with both being
black in a world that doesn't seem to
want him to be in it gay in a black
world that totally doesn't want him to
be that and then at lost with a with a
mother who's a crackhead and on drugs
and no real father figure in his life
except for another drug dealer and just
watching him find a way through
masculinity find a way through manhood
find a way through the world it's so
haunting and it's so moving and it's so
lyrical like there's there are these
moments where you just and they got
three different actors for these parts
who look nothing alike except for the
fact that because they all managed to be
directed the right way they feel like
the same person I notice that in the
trailers like that's supposed to be that
okay thank you that guy in that guy but
it all connects in such a perfect
perfect way the only actors that you
will recognize in any way
guy who was in Luke Cage yeah Hirsch
Allah Ali he's so good he's so good he's
also hidden figures he's the guy that
gets he's the shooter
for fertilizer yeah and Janelle Monae
also in hidden figures plays a his
girlfriend in this one
Janelle monáe wonderful in hidden
figures yeah she's super figures is a
wonderful flick - I love that movie
loved the movie and then there's a Naomi
Harris who was Moneypenny in the James
Bond movies now plays crackhead mom yeah
she's American she plays American she
plays the sort of drug addled mom the
shot by is look good
it looks beautiful shot by James lakhs
and the guy that shot Tuscan yoga I mean
there are these scenes of just this like
the sweat of Miami in the summer you can
see it just like vibrating off of
services there are the whites of the
cars and greens are the trees and the
Blues of the skies and there are these
sequences at night that just especially
on this Beach in Miami that it's just
lit with this glow to it that just it's
tangible like you can feel every frame
in this movie I honestly feel like like
Barry Jenkins wins Best Director for
this well la la Lane wins Best Picture
really because Long Island is that faint
Hollywood loves which is tell us how
much you love Hollywood right it's a
movie about itself whereas moonlight is
absolutely a movie that had been like
hammered into shape by this person and
would not exist if not for this guy and
and his sort of you know dealing with
this sort of roiling cauldron of emotion
and circumstance and Faden inevitability
like all of this is handled with this
perfect precision yeah it's it's a
remarkable movie eloquent review of one
might have heard yet and you've
definitely not pushed me into watching I
wanted to watch for a while I just
haven't got around to it but cuz
everybody's like this movie is amazing
yeah and I want to see it mostly because
of James but uh that that review right
there and the fact that you're number
one yeah everything it'll it'll break
your heart in like three or four
different places mmm
that man that's kind of it we're
middle-aged men we like [ __ ] that
hitters here yeah I find a way I cry
without having a car that's that's a
[ __ ] impressive list man thanks for
taking us through that two episodes to
get there yeah 14 [ __ ] movies to
choose from if you haven't seen some of
them go down the list and fill the holes
plug your holes blog on all Philip lock
it up I mean I can't say that there was
a movie this year that that affected me
that wowed me the way that Mad Max fury
road did super fun movie like in just
it's pure cinema like it's cinema like
in the dictionary what is cinema that
cinema yeah nothing not to become
addicted to water my friend nope don't
gonna drink it anymore and you will
resent its apps but no it was it was a
strong year for movies especially
towards the end of it there it is man
next up my top 10 mm I wonder how many
different what will be on there that's
different than yours what did I say that
I'm like you know arrivals on my list
Zootopia will be on my list spoilers
figure out my list
rogue one will be on your list it's true
there's gonna be a lot of crossover for
sure but hey you don't wanna watch those
episodes [ __ ] skip them [ __ ] set it
the [ __ ] up you just love mark enough to
watch it marks episode skip my [ __ ]
opinion guess what my [ __ ] top 10
list is gonna be yoga hosers yoga hosers
yoga hosers now in Netflix yoga I'm sure
I'm sure there'll be some other films
something I love the rival so as you
could see I could Punk and suck the dick
arrive in a while but I forgot I gotta
go back to my home I forgot about
Deadpool Deadpool is on my list too
I'm telling you man it may be a very
similar list there there was some weird
thing and I like to call it an election
that seems to have broken
the year in Twain that I believed it if
you will leave them in Twain
where there's just movies that came out
in the front end of the year that I
forgot more this year and just
everything had been like October on and
go ahead [ __ ] yeah that's right so the
war was this year oh [ __ ] Deadpool was
this year we're so busy thinking about
all that back end action yeah not about
[ __ ] me up front end action how it
happens in the front piece there it is
man a [ __ ] amazing list ended with a
creepy notion that's fat man I'm Batman
for this week man thanks for hanging out
I'm Ben Kevin Smith and I've been
marking out come back next week or next
episode we'll talk about some more [ __ ]
probably my top ten same fad time same
fat channels Bacchus calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
you